I remembered what I wanted to ask you
and this is the last question they did
come back you're right
did you ever do any ones that they gave
you like scripts like you know some of
them now
those ones do you prefer those ones
because they give you acting notes that
would be [ __ ] frustrating really oh
yeah and I'm very monotone yeah actually
yeah and I remember I won't say what it
was but I was like all right I'm gonna
ham it up right so I was just hamming it
up and then the guys like the the
director is like no but stay it like
this side rich yeah they say it like
this instead and I was like so you want
me to just speak how I normally speak
yeah be more natural yeah yeah I like
this and then when I finally saw the
thing I was like oh I seem so deadpan
that actually doesn't work at all like
never [ __ ] listening to those guys
again but oh I see so the director was a
bad director it's it's you know what a
[ __ ] stories don't belong and porn do
not belong in porn unless we're talking
about doing some avant-garde [ __ ] it
just doesn't [ __ ] work on that it
does it does right if you did it with
like if honestly if I said I take you
let's suppose right now I had I was a
multi-millionaire and I wrote a really
good script a really good script with a
real DP you mean a real like story yeah
I mean yeah and I go you know what we're
gonna take you're gonna take six months
of Meisner technique right right now
you're gonna have this acting coaches
yeah probably Russians Ben Affleck's
acting coach no right what-whatever Nath
likes acting cuz what I would hire him
right I would and I would I would
[ __ ] ago and it would be like a real
movie with a real script with real
emotions right we
story but that sex would be like like
that gas bar no it should it should
movie they should do it like that
yes that one movie love right oh yeah
love was a lot yeah I loved it you know
and it was just it was similar to what
you're describing yeah
Marilyn Brando did a movie called The
Last Tango right not that it was like
you don't you know you don't know you
know I know you don't get the butter but
imagine if you did get a little butter
in there I see I think it could be done
but the powers that be will never let it
happen right and who's that audience for
exactly like who look I've always said
that like the cliche porn is let's say
like the cliche male fantasy is porn in
the cliche female fantasy is a romantic
Hollywood comedy I've kind of always
said that yeah yeah they're both fake so
are you gonna blame romantic Hollywood
comedies when your girlfriend expects
all of these delusional things from you
yeah anyways I've always said that but I
did an another podcast a couple weeks
ago where the woman is a photographer
she's been in the business her whole
life basically and she was saying now
there are people doing more narrative
structures and porn so I haven't seen
those things I can't speak on Rose
necessarily yeah but it doesn't sound
like they're doing full-on big-budget
movies and that is the cool thing night
like you have the ability because the
technology is so much cheaper and
actually have higher quality today than
it was even ten years ago mmm so that I
don't know but what why don't we produce
something yeah what else no you're not
gonna be in it
no distribution okay no what about this
why don't we write a script just for fun
right right right a [ __ ] all right
give me what's the log line what
be thinking yeah well why can't it be
like a real 80 year old man with an 89
already he's Korean his name is Bobby
Lee you know it's set in the hospice
okay really this is your latest fetish
really yeah iiiii there's a company
called old J its o o LD j e.com I also
sometimes go to blue pill men the blue
pill men right and I I also go to
Jurassic [ __ ]